بتكلفة اقل من الاستمرار في
بلاده. حرب الكابلات تستعر بين
اعادة لاجئين سوريين الى بلادهم.
رسالة روسيا للغرب واضحة. فان
التعاون الخليجي والتي ستكون
فيها دول الخليج في وضع افضل من
كوريا الشمالية ومناورات وتعبئة
عامة من قبل الجارة الجنوبية
باقي العالم حينها. فالى ما يلمح
الوزير السعودي. الاحداث
العاصمة التركية انقرة هي الاولى
منذ سنوات. لبنان يستأنف عملية
الوزير عن توقعات الاقتصادية
للسنوات الست المقبلة لدول مجلس
والتطورات. المستشار الالماني في
زيارة الى فرنسا لازالة التوترات
الى قراءة المستقبل. حيث توقع
وزير المالية السعودي محمد
تظهر وقوف السعودية الى جانب
اوكرانيا. فهل يقول البيت الابيض
الصدمة. لكن امريكا لها خط رجعة
مع المملكة لتصرح المتحدثة باسم
الهجمات الاسرائيلية على سوريا
مصرحة انها لن تقف مكتوفة الايدي
الامريكيين. وهنا يقع الامريكان
في الفخ السعودي ليتلقوا بعدها
المتحدة ديمتري بوليانسكي يصرح
من غير المقبول تجاهل الامم
من قرار اوبك بلس تلقى الامريكان
تأكيدات من ولي العهد محمد بن
كوريا الشمالية يمكن ان تكون على
وشك استئناف اختبار نووي هو
بالنسبة لامريكا. فمع استمرار
الشد والجذب بين امريكا
مينسادو بان المكسيك تعارض طرد
روسيا او تعليق عضويتها في
الانواع من الدبابات والمدافع
الى الصواريخ عالية الدقة
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبية ان اي
اختبار نووي من طرف كوريا
المؤسسات والمنظمات الدولية ولن
تنضم للعقوبات ومن اوكرانيا تتجه
للهجمات الجوية. اما المستشار
الالماني فقد وضع خطة مارشال وهي
الروسي في مقطع فيديو ويصرح
كثافة الانتاج الروسي للاسلحة
الكريملين مسبقا عن اختبار الردع
النووي والتزامه بمعاهدة نيوز
الحقيقة ام انه مجرد تنويم
مغناطيسي? ومن العلاقات الحالية
فهل انتهت الحرب? هل انتهى ضجيج
المدافع كي نبني يا سيادة
المستشار? وبين هذا وذاك صرحت
سفيرة المكسيك لدى موسكو نورما
شئتموها نووية فنحن على استعداد
وان اردتموها حربا مدنية فانتم
ويتراوح عددهم بين عشرين وثلاثين
الفا. وقد اشارت المجلة الى ان
سبب لجوء روسيا الى الطائرات
المسيرة يعود الى نفاذ الاسلحة
وروسيا لخوض اشرس المعارك في
خرسون منذ بدء الحرب فهي معركة
بايدن يهنئ نائبته عيد ميلاد
سعيد لرئيس عظيم. فهل نسي انه هو
الرئيس البريطانيون يهربون الى
مصر خوفا من فواتير الغاز اجازة
الى الحرب الاستخباراتية ما بعد
ان صرحت المخابرات البريطانية ان
البريطاني في مجال حقوق مجتمع
الميم المثليين بيتر تاتشل.
اعلام اسرائيلي ان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يجري زيارة رسمية الى
ستارت ليخرج ويأمر بتسريع
القرارات الخاصة بالعملية
الرجل صاحب لقب الاكثر قذارة في
العالم الذي لم يستحمال عشرات
امريكا والصين للسيطرة على خطوط
الانترنت في اعماق البحار. وفاة
الاستراتيجية. وان كانت دورية
فقد جاء الوقت المناسب ليرسل
السنين وكان يدخن خمس سجائر دفعة
واحدة فعن اي قذارة نتحدث. قالت
ساحة المعركة. حيث تسعى موسكو
لتجنيدهم نشرهم في حربها مع كييف
سلمان بانه لن يكون هناك تخفيضات
في الانتاج بحسب المسؤولين
الخاصة الافغانية يحصلون على
عروض عمل لنوع مختلف تماما من
الجدعان ان منطقة الشرق الاوسط
ستواجه ست سنوات عجاف. حيث كشف
الدب الروسي مجلة تحدثت قائلة
الكوماندوز المهجورون في القوات
تايمز الامريكية وبتقرير مطول
تحدثت فيه ان مسؤولين امريكيين
بين البلدين. اوقفت الشرطة
القطرية مظاهرة نظمها الناشط
الشمالية برد لا مثيل له. فكيف
سيرد المجنون وامريكا تكشف عن
في ادارة الرئيس جو بايدن يعتقد
انهم ابرموا صفقة نفط مع
الهزيمة السياسية اسوأ ما قد
تتعرض له اقوى الدول وهو الحال
الورطة بينما الكرملين يتوعد تل
ابيب بالرد. ثلاث دول تهدد كوريا
روسي متواصل وسياسة متبعة. اضرب
ثم فاوض. هنا فلاديمير بوتين
جديدة عابرة للقارات فهل وصلت
الرسالة لتثني امريكا على روسيا
الرئيس الروسي رسالته للغرب وقد
لخصها بتجربة منظومات صاروخية
العسكرية في اوكرانيا. لتأتي هنا
الضربة التي قد تكون القضية من
البيت الابيض للصحفيين. لقد
لاحظنا الخطوات الاخيرة التي
سبعة عقود. صواريخ باليستية تحلق
بشكل متكرر وحالة تأهب دائم من
الاخضر بينما تجري كوريا
الجنوبية مناورات برمائية ردا
الشمالية تعرف بتقدمها العسكري
اما الجنوبية فبتقدمها
على استفزازات كوريا الشمالية
الكوريتان في حالة حرب اكثر من
العجاف. فما القصة؟ وجه بوتين
الجديد. القوة ثم القوة منهج
بناظوره العسكري. يشاهد ويحرك
مناورات للقوات النووية
والسعودية وتوتر العلاقات بين
البلدين كشفت صحيفة نيويورك
المتحدة. نداءات دمشق حول انتهاك
مجالها الجوي من قبل اسرائيل.
السعودية لكن تبين لاحقا ان ذلك
معاكس لتوقعاتهم. وحتى قبل ايام
اخافتهم وقد حان وقت المواجهة
لتعلنها الولاية المتحدة
التكنولوجي. فكيف ستكون النهاية?
السعودية تضع الملح في واشنطن.
ولن تصمت دون رد مناسب. نائب
المندوب الروسي لدى الامم
الفخ الذي نصبته لها السعودية.
وزلات لسان بايدن لا تتوقف
الشمالية سيقابل برد لا مثيل له
حيث تعتقد واشنطن وحلفاؤها ان
موجهة لاعادة اعمار اوكرانيا
وقال انه ينبغي البدء بها فورا.
الطاحنة. لمن ستكون الغلبة
برأيكم? ومن ساحة الحروب الروسية
عين الدب الروسي الى اسرائيل.
لتهدد موسكو تل ابيب وذلك بسبب
ومظاهرة للمثليين في هذا البلد
العربي والشرق الاوسط يواجه الست
المجنون في ورطة. ثلاثة ضد واحد
ليس عدلا. نعم. ضربات كين
والطائرات من دون طيار تزداد
بكثافة تستعد لترد الولايات
والمعدات العسكرية الخاصة مستمرة
وغير متوقفة حيث ان اعداد جميع
المتحدة وتعلن انها ستسلم صواريخ
هوك الدفاعية والهدف التصدي
الدقيقة وبعيدة المدى لروسيا
ليظهر هنا نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
لبناء قوات الدفاع والامن
الافغانية. بينما تستعد اوكرانيا
الولايات المتحدة كانت قد انفقت
ما يقرب من تسعين مليار دولار
في اتصال نادر منذ بداية الحرب
على اوكرانيا وذلك بعدما اعلن
الكرامة بالنسبة للطرفين كل
منهما قد اعد العدة لهذه الحرب
روسيا على العلن. والمانيا ترسم
خطة جديدة لاخراج اوكرانيا من
فماذا عن فلسطين ايها
العثمانيون? وبعد اتهام الغرب
روسيا وموسكو تهدد تل ابيب فيما
تركيا تستقبل وفدا اسرائيليا
روسيا بنفاذ اسلحتها موسكو ترد
بهذا الرد المستفز والميكس تؤيد
مليارات الدولارات وبوتين يأمر
بالاستعجال وواشنطن تثني على
تستخدم الجيش الذي دربته
الولايات المتحدة وصرفت عليه
من سيخسر في وهكذا يرددها الروم.